with Link's Awakening being released on
the switch not a week ago Zelda fans all
over the world are being introduced or
reintroduced to the special world of :
Thailand if you spend five minutes
online searching for videos or Let's
Plays about the remake you'll see one
word in particular come up quite a bit
and that is cu te ki ute it's no secret
that Nintendo has simply outdone
themselves this time around with the
remake of Link's Awakening featuring a
completely revamped art style of cute
clay like chibi appearances for all the
characters and enemies in a cute game
filled with cute monsters and even cuter
people one character in particular
stands out above the rest of them and
that is the first character you see in
game after Link's shipwreck if you've
ever heard of Link's Awakening you've
heard of the strangely familiar meirin
the sweet seaside girl who's obsessed
with singing seagulls and maybe even
link and who's also oddly the only one
aware of the fact that there's a world
outside the island but now's probably a
good time to say if you haven't played
the game yet and care about spoilers be
warned that from this point forward in
the video I may spoil quite a bit of
plot for the game so if that's you and
you don't want to hear it from me the
first time go play the game and after
you've had a great run through it come
back here and listen to my theory about
who and what she could actually be
alright now that the warnings out of the
way without further ado here we go so to
recap meirin and the events of the game
basically for the majority of links
adventure meirin can be found next to
the weathercock singing a very ominous
yet very soothing tune the ballot of the
wind fish this is peculiar when you
understand just what that song means and
how it's used in regards to meirin and
the island itself at the southern face
shrine in the game it's revealed that
the entire : island is but an illusion
check it out to the finder the Isle of
coland is but an illusion
human monster sea sky a scene on the lid
of a sleepers I awake the dreamer and
coho lint will vanish much like a bubble
on a needle cast away you should know
the truth
this is written in the exact same text
style that we later see the wind fish
himself speaking in giving the
impression that this shrine holds a
message directly from the wind fish to
the castaway also known as link after
link defeats the final nightmare within
the egg itself he plays the Ballad once
again at the end of the game to awaken
the wind fish and himself and thus wipe
away the dream of cofilin Island along
with all its inhabitants bringing this
back to Maren it's rather odd that she
would instinctively know this fateful
tomb being an inhabitant of the dream
herself unless of course she was from
someone else's dream but I'm getting
ahead of myself as I mentioned before
Maren is a character that is all too
familiar to fans of the Zelda franchise
she's a redheaded girl who wears a dress
and enjoys singing who lives with her
father whose name Taryn is only one
letter different than her own and begins
with a tea instead of an M another
recurring character we see in the Zelda
universe is Malin the farmer girl most
known from ocarina of time and by the
way if you've watched much of my stuff
here at Maskin Pando bandit you'll
realize I refer to ocarina of time a
locked but anyway
Malin from ocarina of time is also a
redheaded girl who wears a white dress
and enjoys singing she lives with her
father Talon whose name is also very
similar to her own but begins the tea
instead of an M it's obvious that Maren
and Milan bear uncanny resemblances even
their fathers Talon and Taryn are both
oddly similar to Mario who of course is
from the Mario franchise so why am i
pointing out all these similarities well
I tend to believe that this is no
coincidence
if Nintendo wanted to make a Malin or
Marin character again they would have
just put her in the game Nintendo have
no problem with recurring characters of
the same name like Beadle for instance
who appears in Wind Waker Skyward Sword
breath of the wild and more or even
Zelda and link themselves but yet meirin
being basically the same character is
distinctly not Malin so why did Nintendo
make her instead of Milan or vice versa
the answer I believe is twofold one this
is not Hyrule or even the same reality
as Hyrule
as mentioned before and as you already
know if you've completed the game :
Thailand doesn't actually exist not in
real terms anyway it stated that at the
start of the game link was traveling by
sea back to his homeland of Hyrule after
training abroad in distant lands which
is when he shipwrecked in a storm and
woke up inside the dream on the island
link wasn't even in Hyrule when he
entered this dream world giving it no
connections whatsoever so Malin
appearing in a reality other than that
of which we normally experience Zelda
games in is the first reason
the second reason will also require some
explaining unlike every other inhabitant
of ko hole in Thailand I believe that
Marin does not originate from the dream
of the wind fish Marin originates from
the dream of link the castaway the other
dreamer think about it she's the only
one who not only understands there is
land beyond the sea but also has a
desire to leave much like link desires
to wake up and leave she also has that
surreal knowledge of the wind fish and
the one song that will cause him and
Link to awaken and subsequently her
entire reality to disappear but she
doesn't seem very disturbed by that she
also has a certain interest in link who
most fans would like to find romantic in
nature and in the segment of the game
where Marin follows link around she acts
as links in her thoughts scolding him
for hitting a cuckoo but then mumbling
the infamous line of hahaha do it do it
do it more if link continually chops
away at a cuckoo signifying that she
reflects what is inside links in her
mind after the dream has ended Marin is
also the only character that link
actually sees outside of copelan's
Island all of this means that she
actually didn't originate from the wind
fish's dream but from links and with her
eerily accurate similarities to Mao on I
think it's rather obvious that Marin is
a memory echo of sorts of Milan but
here's where things get pretty
speculative if we look at the timeline
closely we see that this is indeed the
same link from the game a Link to the
Past what we also see by this
information is that this link hasn't
ever met Mallon who appeared in ocarina
of time so how then could he dream up
Marin if he's never met
while this is as previously stated
simply speculation I think that Maron is
a spiritual echo of Milan it's a common
belief that the link from ocarina of
time ended up with Milan from ocarina of
time some evidence for this could be
that his direct descendant The Twilight
Princess link is a farmer that already
knows Epona's song which is a song that
Milan taught to Ocarina of Time link
that her mother created since all links
share the same spirit of the hero
regardless of if they're related by
blood or not they are all connected
spiritually it's possible that Milan
loved the hero of time so much that her
spirit bound itself to his eternally to
keep watch over him
this gives meirin's favor towards link
in Link's Awakening some deeper meaning
as well another possibility is that
while this still could be a romantic
infatuation of sorts with link if she
did indeed marry the hero of time and
become an ancestor to future links it
could also be viewed as somewhat
maternal she calls him a sweet boy and
wants to know more about him and also
teaches him the song that will
ultimately save his life from drowning
at sea these are also things that a
mother would do this theory also leaves
room for the fact that when link thought
her up in his mind initially he gave her
Zelda's facial features since he's never
met Malin before another reason why
Maren originated from link and not the
wind fish so is Marian and echo of Milan
I think so but what do you think comment
below with your thoughts and findings
and let me know if I missed anything
that would change my thesis I gave you
guys a teaser picture a couple days ago
and man was it solved quickly but the
wind goes to cage 23 who guessed it
right off the bat so cage 23
congratulations if you're watching this
right now give us a comment below
proclaiming your victory I'm gonna have
to start making these teasers a bit more
difficult in the future thank you so
very much for watching my theory if you
enjoyed this content please leave a like
so that it can get spread around on
YouTube and help the channel out if you
love Zelda which a lot of smart people
do check out all my other theories and
top 10 lists about the franchise and
subscribe if you haven't already for all
my new Zelda content in the future huge
thank you as always to all my amazing
patreon supporters including
newest supporter Chris Simpson I'm
always eternally grateful for all of
your support and hope to continue
improving and impressing you with my
content feel free to check out the links
in my description to check out my
patreon page and join my discord server
full of the finest of zelda fanatics i
think that's about all I've got for this
video so once again thank you ever so
much for watching I'll see you all next
time
this is mast antennae bandit signing out
please
[Music]
[Music]